Pixar...the studio behind this,
and this, and this
has mastered a sort of
photo-surrealistic style
where there’s a sense of cartoony-ness
but most things look and feel like they
could exist in the real world.
Like these fibers on Mr. Incredible’s shirt.
And this tree stump and grass from
this scene from Up.
Or the glimmering, out-of-focus bokeh
behind Bo Peep.
And it’s not just Pixar.
These movies look so similar
you can barely tell they’re from
different animation studios.
But when you look at these movies
it’s clear that something different
is happening.
These lights don’t just illuminate;
they reveal a texture.
This tree in the background
isn’t out of focus
it’s just got a simplified look.
And this hair looks more like
brush strokes than human hair.
These films are part of a new trend
that’s steering animation away from
replicating the real world
and into somewhere new.
Crafting beautiful animation in CG films
requires a lot of dedicated artists
to perform specialized tasks:
like rendering.
Rendering is the process by which
a computer takes
geometry, textures, lighting, camera inputs
and does a bunch of math
to apply all that information into
a final image.
Like this one.
Most render engines, like the one I’m using
here, are physically based
which essentially means that
it tries to replicate the real world physics
of light, shadow, reflection, and more.
You can see this type of rendering
all over Pixar’s work
even going back to their first movie.
Rex looks like he could exist
in the real world.
Every meeting we would have, everybody
brought up like the Pixar look.
The Pixar look was something that was very
high quality
very successful at the box office
so everybody kind of wanted the Pixar look.
My name is Christos Obrenetov.
Christos is the CEO of Lollipop Shaders
a company that builds custom shaders
and plugins for 3D software.
He’s worked on tons of films
including "Life of Pi", "A Christmas Carol,"
and the upcoming "Across the Spider-Verse".
But before all that
he worked on a bunch of films that tried to
replicate that Pixar look.
Because it was reliable, popular, and safe.
Part of doing a feature film is, you know,
a lot of money and a lot of time.
So they were kind of chasing that Pixar dream
of having that kind of a success.
So to go and spend, you know, $100 million
or more...
the investors and what not
are probably saying:
"It's got to look like Pixar or Disney."
Right?
And that was the case for a long time.
Even when studios wanted to try
something different:
Disney would come up and interview for a movie
that ended up being called "Bolt".
They were showing us this really cool concept
art and they're like,
"Oh, it's going to be super stylized."
"It's going to look like sort of like
the concept art."
And it was very exciting.
I was like, "Oh, this is great."
And then when the movie
did come out
I mean, Bolt is fantastic, but they made it
very, you know, that same look.
Movies like "Monster House" and "A Christmas
Carol" were intended to look stylized too
but ultimately they settled back into
that tried-and-true
physically based rendering look.
There were glimmers of more stylized approaches
in short film tests
and small sequences like in Disney’s Moana.
But this stylized sequence
is only about 30 seconds
out of the hour and 43 minute-long film.
A lot of studios have been playing with
this for a long time.
But to take that risk
to do a full feature film that's
very stylized in 3D
I think people were scared.
And that fear kept studios from making
bold choices.
Until 2017 when the trailer for
"Into the Spider-Verse" dropped.
It had simplified graphic bursts that felt
like comic book panels.
There was no motion blur or depth of field
and everything, from the characters to the
environments, was full of texture.
According to one of the animation supervisors
for the project
after a year and a half of work
the studio was still nervous that people were
going to hate the visuals.
Because they felt like they were taking too
many risks.
Instead of leaning into the safe, physically
based, rendering look
"Into the Spider-Verse" chose to use
non-photorealistic rendering.
To pull this off, they essentially had to
break their physically-based renderer.
Instead of inputting data from lights,
camera, and materials
and receiving a realistic looking render
they combined all that data with custom
data passes that tweaked things like
the focus plane or the way the light worked
in an image.
This combo allowed the renderer
to produce stylized results.
For example, in "Into the Spider-verse",
out of focus elements aren’t blurry.
Instead, the colors split
as if the screen printing on an actual
comic book was done poorly.
Lighting and shadow were approached
in new ways too.
Light often reveals halftone dots.
And shadows create sketchy hatch marks.
But there’s more than just shading magic
happening here.
Non-photorealistic renderings often use linework
2D elements like speed lines and doubles
and variable frame rates to pull these frames
further away from reality
and often, closer to the concept art.
Just two months after its release
"Into the Spider-Verse" became the highest grossing
film Sony Pictures animation
had ever made.
It doesn’t hold a candle to Pixar
in terms of lifetime gross:
"Incredibles 2" sits at the number one spot
while Spider-verse doesn’t even crack
the top 50.
But, much like Pixar did in the first wave
of CG animated features
"Into the Spider-Verse" redefined
the visual goals for animation studios.
2021’s "The Mitchells vs the Machines" and
2022’s "Puss in Boots"
take non-photorealistic rendering in a different,
more painterly direction
where out-of-focus objects
become simplified shapes
emulating the way that artists may use
simplified marks in backgrounds
"In the Mitchells vs the Machines", shadows
create different marker textures.
Puss in Boots’ simplified 2D cutaways mimic
the graphic bursts of Into the Spider-verse.
People were like, "Oh, this is looks really
good and it's different".
So now, all future projects at studios from
DreamWorks and Imageworks and Pixar—
they're looking at the next whatever, five
years or whatnot.
It's all like very stylized.
And that’s really exciting
because non-photorealism allows animated movies
to take advantage of
the things that make them special.
They can be anything the imagination allows.